I'll be the princess it's a love story
baby just say yeah me yeah tell me we
try to tell you how to feel this love is
typical but it's the real deal
how's it going breasts - welcome to Eric
we're gonna continue the journey of
satellite house and hopefully we'll
figure out the secrets of the island
learn some new skills have a good time
in general how did that sound you know
you can see your little smirk all right
we got that the loading screen is the
bus this [ __ ] [ __ ]
how's this piece of [ __ ] not loaded yet
alright then we're back on the beach
click the graphics man the game runs a
little better doesn't it
22 fps that's better than 15 I think I
look at Dinah so ok torch oh oh oh oh oh
well then nevermind it
excuse me I'll go this way a little lost
kind of feel like I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm doing
let's check our image what can we make
our cameltoe that long look at dad
Camuto oh my god dad
and then maybe we can kill some
dinosaurs that'd be cool
that'd be cool cousin you can get a
little [ __ ] excited oh my god what
was that
what the [ __ ] in my ass a male dildo rah
rah get away get away get away get away
now it would agree I killed him you ass
oh [ __ ] I killed a dinosaur take our
take our pad stop it's tackling me
tickle tickle
I'd stop it you're killing me over here
literally hahaha
you [ __ ] spit up you know that
[ __ ] hole well we get way more wood
if you use oh my god that makes sense so
much easier to farm now timber yes
that's right some fiber here some fiber
there make the fiber trees go everywhere
that's what my mom I always said when i
farm fiber i mean business [ __ ] just
[ __ ] flies everywhere look at this
[ __ ] all right all right mr. Triceratops
you will not be so alive atop seni more
all right let's get him right where he
likes it does not have level two that
should be easy right all right now we
run now we play the running game
I just [ __ ] my pants literally haha
alright I ride all right it's okay it's
okay we are smarter handsomer you know
it might not be handsomer now I think
about it but we are smarter hey they're
gonna fat Oh God the music stopped I
thought we were cool are we cool I don't
know oh my god that crazy ass mouthful
dick Jeff
oh I hate him I hate him right in the
shoulder I'm starving
all right well I really need to kill you
then all right did I miss I just missed
the night oh my god this is really bad
news for me I think he's stuck he's
[ __ ] stuck
no he's too stuck you see or none oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god I get it get
a get that boom oh [ __ ] my [ __ ] sake
stop we're ready ready to rock baby baby
baby bear we should kill something and
we need more meat oh my god I just [ __ ]
my pants I'm so sorry it was it was the
turtle I swear
now man that's not cool that ain't me
really
take this god damn it it worked in
Pokemon
I don't understand
that's [ __ ] literally kind of [ __ ]
we're running low in hunger again this
is ridiculous how much does this beat
alright you know what I'm a beast I eat
a lot I get it
solid asses hungry as [ __ ] [ __ ] second I
think my shoulders are too wide damn it
alright then [ __ ] oh you're so cute
Oh survival of the fattest [ __ ]
please please I'm [ __ ] dying come on
Matt how's it going you're starving it
come on just cook just cook I'm so close
to dying come on cook you son of a [ __ ]
I'm sorry bro
they're so cute I hate myself [ __ ] why
do I keep [ __ ] I need to [ __ ] you
need to eat so much in this [ __ ] game
no wonder I [ __ ] like a boss could make
a box
hey boxes are pretty cool right yes can
I get some love for some boxers yeah
box that's cool why wouldn't I not wanna
make a box we're tired we need we need a
chill oh my god why do I take a [ __ ] all
day God you don't talk to the [ __ ] do
not talk alright shut up Jesus crisis
build the build of it it's the little
bit I think this is a bed I'm not sure
it could be anything well we're just
gonna have to find oh my god that's
beautiful
yes hold for more options demolish Wow
amazing
wow thanks stupid stupid stupid stupid I
hate you I hate you I hate you I hate
you oh my god they lit up so beautifully
should we go to one of them yeah let's
try that I don't know what else to do
honestly
we're all the dinosaurs there at this
party or some [ __ ] that I'm missing out
on oh my god stop by later poop my
parents it's raining now oh my god
that's awesome okay cool I can dig I
don't think I can think of this game
actually hey fun
hella Bettis yeah Buffy dad don't die
now don't die now
yeah just [ __ ] molest my body while
you're at it
holy [ __ ] I was not ready for that
that's scare the [ __ ] out of me oh my
god god damn it
alright press now it's a great time
during this episode and I can go and cry
[ __ ] alright they were like if you want
more breasts I would love to do more for
you and I'll see you the next one
brothers leave a comment about rafters
[ __ ] and I'll see you